on prime crime this is the most horrific
crime that i had ever seen the case
that cannot be forgotten oh god
can only someone truly insane have
committed these acts
these are all behaviors of someone who
is completely
unaware of the severity of their
behaviors
the turns that no one could see coming
i'm just concerned
[Music]
hey there everybody i'm jesse webber and
welcome to prime crime
this is where we do a deeper dive into
the most high profile
and memorable true crime cases now this
next case is very unique
both in terms of its details and the
legal question
on mental illness we
did advise you of your your rights is
that correct yes sir
all right can you just state your name
the man authorities are speaking to is
timothy jones jr
timothy jones jr was described as
borderline
genius and insanity smart man he worked
at intel
jones was the father of five young
children out in south carolina
mira was the oldest she was eight she
was kind of the protector
sort of acted as a pseudo-mother elias
he was seven he didn't know a stranger
in class he sat next to all the kids
was very friendly the two youngest ones
two and one years old abigail and
gabriel
natan was the third child
he had it perhaps the most difficult
the kids were very close and what was
most striking is they
loved their dad jones and the kid's
mother
amber kaiser had divorced after a rocky
marriage
as part of their separation jones
received custody
have you ever been told that you had a
mental illness by a doctor
just anybody i've had oh yeah you're
nuts dude
my nickname in high school was the crazy
white guy
timothy jones jr's mother was diagnosed
schizophrenic
and she had been institutionalized for
several decades now
but when he was a baby his father
alleged that she would
bathe him in cold water she would scream
at him while he was crying
she would leave him to cry she was
described as a neglectful mother
tim jones jr had spent some time in
prison in illinois
prior to all of this for a stolen car
drug charges it was completely unrelated
but when he got out
he was obsessed with religious teachings
of the bible
this became truly apparent by how he
treated his children
i just pt disaster couldn't handle it
and when you're saying pt and what are
we talking about squats and push-ups
how how long were you having them pt pt
like an hour
running laps around the house doing
pull-ups um sit-ups
squats those were the forms of
punishment when the kids
did not behave at least in tim jones
jr's mind and they were always
um you know please daddy please no i
don't want to i'm tired
apparently it was to no avail i'm old
school in a sense that i think
kids should get their ass busted by a
teacher jones
discipline of his kids is interesting
because
it does seem to adhere to a lot of sort
of
religious doctrine and things like that
but also
i think it has a lot to do with his own
upbringing
i think there was a lot of fear about
his parents he's going far beyond what
is completely
necessary for discipline i think he
sees them more as objects to be treated
of
and disposed of as he sees fit
fast forward to august 28 2014
after a tense phone call jones hangs up
on amber kaiser
kaiser continually calls jones back
tim i'm not i'm not calling to argue or
anything i just
for like the past two or three phone
calls you've been
like really on edge you're saying you're
like coming off really frustrated or
whatever
and i'm just concerned about you so
please call i'm not not calling to argue
or anything
but her calls keep going to voicemail
after that jones and the kids are
nowhere
to be found days later
jones is stopped at a checkpoint in
mississippi
but there's no sign of the children they
said he was like sweating
profusely acting a little erratically
one of the investigators i think he was
with the fbi said basically enough
where are the kids they're missing what
happened
what did you do coming up what jones
ends up telling investigators
still shakes people to this day
and something happened that night is
that correct yes sir
and then and then you you find out what
then just
in 2014 timothy jones jr is located by
authorities
after it's reported he and his five
children have gone missing for several
days
when he's interviewed by police and the
fbi they want to know what happened to
the kids
jones begins to lay out the timeline of
events it allegedly starts from a
conflict with his six-year-old son natan
a town about four outlets that he blew
after a series of not getting any
favorable responses out of him i tried
to use more harsh measures to just try
to get out of him what was going on
because i didn't know
what he was doing tried cracking one
butt a couple times to get something out
of him to tell me what was he doing
right what's his motive i sent him bet
after i worked him real hard because he
wouldn't answer me
come back and find out that he's
deceased
there were some light sockets blown out
inside their trailer
and he thought natan had been messing
with them and was trying to kill him
by jimmy rigging the electrical sockets
and because natan would not admit to
that
he started to make natan run laps around
the house
for what was described later as hours
once that happened
tim jones jr told the investigators he
sent a time to bed and when he went to
check on the time
tom was dead i worked him too hard or
maybe it was a combination of the
electricity
if i would have known him about i mean i
would have gotten medical help what not
it's what jones does next though that
turns this story of an alleged accident
into a horrible nightmare the voices
start going off and then here comes the
paranoid oh shit
what just happened what what what just
happened
and that followed suit with the other
four
and how did how did you feel with my
hands
around their neck around their neck for
the first child
it was this excessive amount of physical
training
but then for the rest of the children it
was strangulation
[Music]
used about two who do you remember using
the valtan
babies were the older did they put up a
fight
i mean what person's not it's expected
that as soon as the parent sees all this
pain and suffering going on in the faces
of their children that they're gonna
stop
so then what's going on within jones
that's telling him to keep
going he was not viewing them as human
beings he was not viewing them
as his offspring he wasn't viewing them
even as just children
he was simply viewing them as objects
things that he could easily get rid of
notice earlier that eli said something
to you before you killed him what did he
say to you
pick me with dad did any of the other
children say anything
before you killed them okay well
i love you after murdering his children
now jones had to figure out what to do
next
at that point i we're just thinking
run get rid of the bodies in your town
why'd you buy those trash bags
to do what now to put the bodies
jones drove around the southern united
states with the dead bodies of his
children in his car
for over a week he then proceeded to
place them in garbage bags
and toss them out on an alabama road i
just put them up to the side i knew
there was no hiding bags
there ain't no hardness i'm gonna get
caught this is just a better time
i'm buying myself time you just drove
tim jones jr was driving through
mississippi
and stopped at a sobriety checkpoint
just like everybody else
and when the officers went up to his
window the first thing they testified
was an
overwhelming smell and immediately that
officer said he knew that was a smell of
severe
human decomposition had he not
stopped at this random checkpoint in the
middle of
mississippi he very well could have made
his way to the border at least according
to prosecutors
and gotten away up next
jones crimes are sickening but is he not
responsible
due to insanity they calm the voices
down inside my head
to let me be at peace and not act on
them
[Music]
this was not premeditated this was oh
shit what just happened
in 2014 south carolina father timothy
jones
jr admits to law enforcement that he
killed his five children
he says he may have accidentally
overworked his six-year-old natan to
death
after disciplining him in fact jones
claims that he punished the boy
because he believed he may have been
trying to kill him
jones explains how once he discovered
his son dead
he then killed the other four children
you would think this would be a
straightforward case for the government
however joan's statements and actions
raise the question of whether he's
actually criminally insane
and not legally responsible so the
insanity defense
is different throughout all of the
different jurisdictions in the united
states
but they're all variations of that at
the time of the crime was committed
the person did not know what they were
doing was wrong
an individual could either not know that
it was against the law
or that they were somehow unaware
that this was a breaking of social norms
when you did this crime did you know it
was wrong at the time i didn't think any
of it was wrong it happened and just
let me finish it up now okay when you
did the crime did you know it was
against
the law time i didn't think about the
law so
i'm gonna say no these are all behaviors
and actions of someone who is
completely unaware of the severity of
their behaviors that
they're not in their right mind the
arguments that support the insanity
defense here
go back to his childhood and a lot of
problems that he had
with his family abandonment abuse
mental illness and then he's argued that
he had a hit to the head and he had an
expert talk about that
that can be compelling to a jury if
somebody has a head injury and then
acts out once he discovered tom was dead
he says the voices in his head
told him no one is going to believe this
was an accident so therefore
i have to kill the rest of them when you
did this did you think your actions
could hurt the children
yes it was to protect myself okay
he has this brain injury where the brain
injury
was so the the frontal lobe it helps us
make
rational decisions with it being damaged
he's no longer
stopping himself from just doing
whatever his brain tells him to do
then again jones acts perhaps show that
he did
fully realize what happened
investigators pulled up some of the
google searches on tim jones jr's phone
and one of them was what do extradition
laws mean
there was another search that said
canines searching for bodies
he even googled himself tim jones jr
missing kids
in the days after all of this and
prosecutors alleged that that was
because he was trying to get away with
it he was methodical he knew what he was
doing
he was trying to circumvent the judicial
process and get away with what he did
especially with that search as it
relates to
extradition laws at that point i was
just running on fear and i
wasn't thinking any normal person would
have said let me call the police and
turn myself in okay i took the coward
route
and started following those voices in my
head which
led me down such a nice path i'm on
today
the fact that he had killed one child
and then came back
and tried to kill the others to cover up
the crime that's key
that shows deliberation and that he
arguably was not insane
the time was an accident but you you
murdered the other four children
yes okay if why did you do that
the voices started kicking and said you
better do something now
in the end it's the jurors who had to
decide jones guilt
in what would be a heart-wrenching trial
think all court shows are the same we're
talking about your father
guilty or not guilty guilty think again
judge caprio rules with common sense i
was having contractions i was rushing to
the hospital inspector quinn what does
justice demand
jail and compassion i'm going to take
the
circumstances into consideration the
best court experience i've had
clearly judge he's been in a court
before get caught
in providence
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions
welcome to prime crime tonight another
day of drama between both sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the law on crime network is everywhere
and we invite you
inside the jury box this is law and
crime
i've seen people i've had conversations
i've started to talk with people
when there's nobody in the room
2019 south carolina timothy jones jr is
on trial for the horrifying murders of
his five young children
back in 2014. not only did he confess to
law enforcement about the killings
but he explained how he drove around for
days with their dead corpses
threw their bodies in garbage bags and
then tossed his kids out in alabama
before police finally apprehended him
father was supposed to love his children
tim jones loved himself more
the father is supposed to protect his
children
tim jones was worried about protecting
himself more
because of a mental disease or defect
tim could not appreciate
legal or moral right from wrong
tim jones jr's defense was not so much
that he didn't do it but that he didn't
have control over what he did because he
was clinically insane
they made a big point of tim jones jr
getting into a car accident at 15
the traumatic brain injury that he
suffered what that could mean
pointed out the fact that his mother is
schizophrenic there's mental illness in
the family
lots of different aspects to ultimately
try to prove
that he didn't have control over his
actions there were internal voices
telling him to do this tim jones jr was
very stoic
he cried a little bit but one of the
things i noticed about
when he would cry he wore glasses he had
a handkerchief
and he would kind of make that crying
face he would take his glasses off and
he would dab his eyes but i never saw
actual tears the trial was filled with
painful moments
but perhaps one of the most memorable
was when amber kaiser
the mother of these deceased children
took the stand
she first described a chilling call she
had
the night prosecutors allege jones
killed the kids
i heard my son crying
and i asked him what was wrong
he said mom i didn't mean to
and tim got mad and and said why do you
always have to defend the kids
it was when kaiser read aloud a letter
she wrote to her eight-year-old daughter
mira
she just couldn't take it anymore
oh god
[Music]
my baby
[Music]
nobody expected her to break down like
that
on the stand even the prosecutor who i
talked to after the fact
said that was not anywhere in their
pre-trial conversations that came out of
nowhere
after weeks of testimony and over six
hours of deliberations
the jury reached their decision we the
jury fund as follows
as to indictment 188 mira
guilty as to indictment 189
elias guilty
as to indictment 190 abigail
guilty as to indictment 191
gabriel guilty
as to indictment 195 natan
guilty i think the jury found him guilty
because
jurors cannot believe that a parent
would kill their child
no jury is going to say a that's not
murder
and b he suffers from insanity
knowing that he's not going to go to
prison
because you want him punished for that
and you want accountability for that
now it was all about the sentencing for
jones
life in prison or the death penalty
during this phase of the trial emotions
ran high once again
whether it was when jones father
displayed a tattoo of his grandchildren
on his back
or when amber kaiser shocked us all once
again
do you want tim put to death
i personally myself can't bring myself
to want anybody to die
he did not show my children mercy by any
means
but my kids loved him
you know if i'm speaking on behalf of my
kids and not myself that's what i would
have to say
i feel enormous compassion for her
i mean i think that's a real act of
grace that she did that
it's commendable but it didn't save him
did it
we the jury in the above entitled case
now recommend to the court that the
defendant be sentenced to death
at the time of this recording jones sits
on death row
awaiting his execution as for amber
kaiser
she's filed a lawsuit against the
department of social services
who she claims could have done more to
stop jones
the case against the state they knew
that he was abusive towards the kids
they had sick safety plans that they
didn't follow up on at all
if you're going to come in as a state
then don't fail those kids don't just
come in
and then stand back and not do anything
this is a case that took a toll
on many it's been reported that the
jurors and even members of the
prosecution
are still unnerved by what was presented
in court
that includes one moment that was
incredibly eerie
and poignant one of natan's favorite
toys according to his babysitters and
his family was his little woody doll
and the woody doll was found in their
home
after the fact with its head ripped off
it had been torn apart it had been
destroyed
it was placed on the table in front of
the jury and when the prosecutor pulled
the woody doll
out of the bag it said man am i glad to
see you guys
and it would the whole room went silent
it was very haunting because the doll
had been in a bag for four years with
double a batteries everyone expected the
batteries to be dead
the prosecutor said what a sense of
justice
it was an incredible moment in the trial
that nobody
could have predicted
this is one of the most devastating
crimes that we've ever covered on the
program
the faces of these children will remain
in the minds of many people and you have
to imagine that includes the members of
the south carolina attorney general's
office
because at the time of this recording
they're working to oppose
jones appeal making sure he continues to
answer
for his crimes and that's all we have
for you here on prime crime
leave us your comments on instagram and
twitter with the hashtag
primecrime as always thank you for
joining us
and until next time be safe
[Music]
you